(people cheering)
- [Narrator] The defending
champion US Women's Soccer team
is going into their first World Cup
since agreeing to share their prize money
with the US Men's team.
- It's just gonna be very competitive.
It's gonna be the most watched World Cup.
It's gonna be the best one yet.
- [Narrator] The Americans are going
after an unprecedented
third consecutive World Cup championship.
But that's not the only
goal on players' minds.
- There's still a big discrepancy
between the men's prize money
from FIFA and the women's, and
to me, that's unacceptable.
- [Narrator] FIFA is a
nonprofit organization.
This year, they've more than
tripled the total prize money
for the Women's World
Cup compared to 2019.
But the $110 million
announced by FIFA in March
is a fraction of what the
men received just last year.
- We still have a lot of fight left
and there's a lot of room for improvement.
(team chanting indistinctly)
- The US is the most successful team
in FIFA Women's World Cup history,
winning the tournament four times.
The only team with more World Cup Gold
is Brazil's men's team with five titles.
US Forward Christen Press
won back-to-back titles
in 2015 and 2019
but has been sidelined
for a year with an injury.
- When we won the World Cup in 2015,
it became abundantly clear
that the way that we were being valued
by our employer did not match
the way that we were valued
by the world.
- [Narrator] Press is one of
the players who filed a lawsuit
against the US Soccer Federation
for gender discrimination just ahead
of the 2019 tournament in France.
- When you play in a World Cup,
you really shut out the world.
You have to be dedicated and
focused entirely on your craft
on what happens between the lines.
But yet we had that drum beat
in the back of our minds that
this was for something bigger.
- [Narrator] The lawsuit alleges a number
of inequalities compared
to the men's team,
including pay disparities,
training conditions, and game promotion.
In its response, the US
Soccer Federation argued
that the men's and women's
team were not comparable
because of their different schedules,
obligations, and compensation
and that the women's
team had no counterparts
on the men's team.
The US Soccer Federation did not reply
to a request for comment.
- [Crowd] Equal pay, equal pay, equal pay.
- [Narrator] After a
three-year legal battle,
the players and US Soccer
reached a $24 million settlement.
Both the men's and the women's
team reached new labor deals
with US Soccer that
aligned the team's pay.
The two teams also agreed to pool
and share their prize money
from their respective World Cups.
(lively music)
This year's tournament
will include more teams,
more prize money, and more
fanfare than ever before.
The Women's World Cup debuted in 1991,
61 years after the first men's tournament.
In recent years,
the women's event has made
large gains in viewers
but its prize money remains far
behind the men's tournament.
FIFA says the 2019 Women's World Cup
in France drew 1.1
billion viewers worldwide,
31% of the almost 3.6 billion people
who watched the 2018
Men's World Cup in Russia
but it awarded the women just 7.5%
of the $400 million prize
money that it awarded the men.
In June, FIFA announced
that for the first time
in a Women's World Cup,
a portion of the prize money
would be earmarked specifically
for the players.
In the past, federations
generally decided how much
of the prize money to give players.
In a statement, FIFA
president Gianni Infantino
called the distribution
model unprecedented.
Each player will earn a minimum of $30,000
with the women on the winning
team getting $270,000.
- Having them direct payments
to the players is huge.
I mean, it's a life-changing thing
for some of these players.
- [Narrator] The payment
model for 2023 was welcomed
by FIFPRO, an umbrella organization
that represents 65,000 men's
and women's soccer players
and their unions worldwide.
- The biggest thing probably
at the minute is making sure
that the agreement, the
conditions, the compensation system
that we were able to put in place together
with FIFA are actually being implemented.
(pensive music)
- [Narrator] Because of a unique mechanism
in their collective bargaining agreements,
whatever the American women win this year,
they'll share with the US men's team.
It works like this.
Let's say the US women take first place.
FIFA has allotted $4.29 million
in prize money for the 2023
winning member association.
In this example, that's US Soccer.
Each of the 23 players on
the roster gets $270,000.
That's another $6.21 million.
Combined, that's $10.5 million from FIFA
for winning the Women's World Cup.
For the Americans,
that money would get pooled
with what the US Men's team won
for reaching the knockout stage
in their World Cup last year
for a total of $23.5 million.
A portion of that goes to
the US Soccer Federation
and the men's and women's
teams split the rest.
(lively music)
FIFA says it's modernizing
football to be global,
accessible and inclusive in all aspects.
In a video posted on
social media just days
before the 2023 World Cup kickoff,
players from co-host country
Australia highlighted the gap
in FIFA prize money
between the men's and
women's competitions.
- Collective bargaining has allowed us
to ensure we now get the same
conditions as the Socceroos
with one exception.
FIFA will still only offer women 1/4
as much prize money as men
for the same achievement.
- [Narrator] FIFA says
it's aiming for equality
in the prize money for the
2026/2027 World Cup cycle.
That would be a 300%
increase for the women
if the men's prize money
remains at 440 million.
- We're seeing growth across
the globe in the women's game
at a league level, at
an international level.
The support's there, and
I think that is going
to make it the the best World Cup ever.
(pensive music)